ok jetzt hoffentlich klappt seit der
hoffen gestockt okay noch 321 nichts
passiert das funktioniert doch es klappt
ssg zu bekommen zur sechsten fall von
microsoft wanted und wir sind in einer
relativ lustige situation wenn man eine
aufnahme bei dem schon abgehakt ist
und dieser hat versucht sozusagen ist
bei mach ist auf dem channel mit dem hsv
und ich weit gespannten einem zombie
sony ein zombie der engers bereich mache
ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen niedriger
als auch noch vorschläge habt für mich
so wie ich mein haus hüsten hat nur ein
sexy machen könnte dann könnt ihr die
generell ja genau alle es geht können
wir in die kommentare schreiben
er wollte dass ich mein haus balkan habe
ich vielleicht habe ich der bauer bin ja
so der iwf weiter will ja weil ich kann
irgendwie minecraft nicht fehlen ohne
las ich ein haus habe ich bin dann fehlt
immer irgendwie hast ja oder doch
eigentlich recht aber vielleicht braucht
mich auch einfach mal rein
das werde ich kann mich da oben so wenn
ich ganz neues machen wir die treppe
einfach mal einen zurück der im
possibility skript wonach man sich die
treppen kapellen zurückgesetzt
zack geht es gut laufen
okay vielleicht sich einfach einen turm
euch werden sie mal englisch und dazu
dennis und den fabia und können auch
noch ein ja gut da ist groß genug der
turm ja da will ich ja vor der auszeit
regal leute ihr können wir mal die
kommentare ob gewollt dass ich in den
turm ziel oder ob ich mir lieber ein
haus bauen soll
für mich macht keinen großen unterschied
anziehen
ich habe übrigens jetzt gerade in dem ja
sozusagen gescheiterten aufnahme versuch
von gerade eben
ich war mein ganzes zeug wiedergeholt
aus einer kiste
die hatte vor emails angelegt danke fabi
und jan sind wieder voll einsatzfähig 30
schild und wir haben 20 hab glaub ich
fast ccc ich habe 19 leben
wie wirst du 19 ich habe 50 auf 15 auf
studieren eigentlich bin ich es
vollkommen aus der sonne raus aber hier
geht was hast du die 4800 also nicht so
viel krach 1904 mich ist das war
eigentlich ja keine absicht etwas mehr
aber dann ist er wendet sich sogar mehr
sogar noch ein forstwirt habe vieles
forstwirts wir haben und ja bei gut
bekamen viele fonds mit dem prädikat
total easy cent nach ich darf in
sonsbeck hobbys von matthias woche
keiner so machen wir erstmal ich fahre
jetzt ein bisschen pools im raum hof ich
mein haus weiter
wir brauchen natürlich jetzt wie sich
das von außen aus den klassen 8 a ha ich
schon wieder einig hängt schon wieder
wieder versucht aus wurden place zu
kräften
so ich mache jetzt ein bisschen glas um
meine fenster zu verglasen lösen
klasen der hand und werde jetzt hier
fenster so ich hab jetzt auch mal schön
werkzeuge crafted so so 234 und werden
anfang material zu sammeln schönholz und
was könnte man geiler christel eine
aufnahme machen als holzabbau mal
versuchen
ich denke mal ich werde noch eine kleine
tasche um darauf machen
hier wird so mein schlafzimmer denke ich
mal sein oben unten wird so meine
schnelle ab lage sein mit offen und so
weiter mit den ganzen anderen sachen die
man hier noch zugreifen kann ich werd
mir wahrscheinlich zum camping feier die
nächsten folgen machen weil es gibt
einen camping psk ich weiß nicht ob das
heißt habe ich schon mal gehört bei
diesen camps oder machst einfach
rechtsklick drauf auf dem besten was
willst du machen werden und dann ist
alles instant gebraten
der rechtspfleger den besten immer also
es gibt drei verschiedene stufen von
camping feier
das beste von denen gerät einfach alles
instant oscar das machen wir uns am
besten auch das könnte ich auch mal
machen diese folge wo ich hab gerade ich
habe eine richtig geile idee
ich habe gerade was denn die idee dass
ich mir einfach so an den tower sohn bei
kontron balkon und einfach da einst hier
ist der kohl ist voll die gute nehmen
alter geil aber ich weiß nicht ob ich
dir nur aus aus aus loks machen soll
also also als baumstämme oder holz also
mal holz anfang an immer an
also ich blogs blog ist natürlich im
heck mega ressourcen aufwendig jakob
mahl also ich hab hier bei meinem haus
ich will ob sich der staub röter walter
die muss man sich auch ewig fragen habe
ich schaue mal dass wir jetzt auch nicht
loks fahren und dann oben anfangen zu
bauen in dieser folge und dann
vielleicht mal in der nächsten folge
anfangen die ice legion zu töten das ist
ja genau
william war ja schon ist er schon mal
hierher gelaufen ja aber auch screen
habe ich mir sagen
ja das doppelte vollkommen verboten
laufen dabei darf sich falten
ja genau der dann gegen farbige kämpft
deshalb ist er die off screen regel auch
wieder abgeschafft worden ja genau wie
du willst nicht mehr ski gefahren und
habe es kein einziges mal gemacht
ja ich mache mir jetzt noch mal eben aus
wetter wieder dunkler mein bett in mein
haus schon mal und mit eisenmann ist auf
eine neue eisen schaufel schippe ob ich
gesagt er bleibe jetzt über einen stack
loks jetzt mal zum 30 ja die habe ich
auf ski gefahren
ja geil toll aber das ist schade ist es
nicht durfte aber suchen ein stockwerk
aus vielleicht gehen wir einfach mal den
dritten stock obwohl es im echten leben
auch im dritten stock russell programms
alter dritte stock wo hier oben ist
alles kaputt alter frische ja ich glaube
das hier ist ganz gerade mal hier rein
ich mach mir jetzt passgenau und navy
field genau ein spinnweben spielen sie
im väter oder seite erfahren
ein faden ich habe mich also ich habe 23
strings wenn du einfach in meine ich
komme eben eine multi gelaufen weil er
kann ich mir so ein cooles doppelbett
machen was ich machen wollte auf jeden
fall oder so frost die fonds 29 auf ich
töte dich und ich meine so eng machnig
alter stürmer sidney klusmann
ich habe einen super charakter
ich will zuträglich verrecken wo ich
meine volkes rechnung zu ende
echt ich habe schon 16 minuten darauf
baut krass dann hab ich habe ich jetzt
aber auch schon macht fast eine zu
warten gott ich bin so ein produkt
france machen warum 16 schon wieder
warum denn nicht
es ist so eine verschwendung mit loks zu
bauen ganze haus von außen ist nur loks
bei mir alles ist das wachs teilweise
teil wird die lecks bank skyliners das
ist ja muss mal gucken muss ein bisschen
bisschen gewehr um testen würde ich den
film ja aber ich muss sehr genau schaut
man die kommentare von dieser idee
haltet ihr sozusagen balkon zu bauen
balkon manchmal noch ein zweites bett
man habe ich so ein cooles doppelbett in
meinem haus das carport auf euch nicht
ich war verlagert weil man wenn die
kisten in das haus rein aber erst mache
ich das mit dem bett so ich kenne genau
würde gerne hier schlafen weil ich mich
hier menschen ins mädchen hin
und jetzt nicht so natürlich auch schön
die inneren richtung sein habe ich viel
sand ich habe unmengen an sand wenn du
sie brauchst also hier kommt der
massenversand teilnehmen aber ich
brauche auf jeden fall auch ich mache
jetzt einfach mal so ein hallo erstmal
ein bisschen aufräumen mit dem stein
es wird es ein bisschen eng für mich mal
da gibt's auch noch weiter ok krass ok
gras so krass castro ich habe 18 minuten
nur eine spitzhacke doch so nicht sicher
ob das mit dem bett cool ist er ist zu
nah an das echt so nah am fenster recht
ich mache mich noch mal so einfach so
einem fall dinge einfallen kann draußen
sich für diese features es ist schon
wieder dunkel kann zum schlafen ja klar
ich bin hier am bett dann machen wir das
alles klar 13 21 ich war bin ich ich ich
kann damit sofort leute für alle ich
mache mir grad noch ein paar fakten
benedix red und ich glaube ich wenn mein
herz rein und sich jetzt ins bett in
einer männer zwei betten
pünktlich zum vorigen ende habe ich noch
einmal geschlafen und bei mir sind jetzt
gerade bei elfriede in einem fax an die
haben noch ordentlich zeit danach eine
packerin und unten vorm eingang einladen
zwei fackeln
er ist ein richtig kann ich rausnehmen
das fließendes wasser auf unsere brunnen
kann ich kein wasser nehmen doch klar
aus dem brunnen im turm sonja
so ich würde seine freunde aufbauen
wer selber gps in der video beschreibung
und ich würde sagen ist einfach mein
ding gekeltert durch haben wir eine
schneebälle ja ich habe ja klar ich
brauche ich brauche ein alter okay das
wird geil ist geil wenn ich das jetzt
nicht kennen oder was nein nix no kennen
wussten ja keine produkte
auch netzwerk zeigt alles habe ich elf
aber ich brauche noch mehr schnee habe
doch schnee schnee schnee wobei es geht
eigentlich auch das geht eigentlich auch
so ich baute durch das portal einfach
meinen keller einbauen
ganz ungelegen kommen oder was ja
brauchst du mir ganz oben in das ist
cooler ok ich muss hier immer neuen
schnee blöcke das geht nicht so ganz ob
machst machst ganze auf die spitze von
touren alter dass es aus sind ob das ob
das geht ich habe jetzt einfach meinen
fall noch einfach einen blog gemacht
oder jemand mega viele herzen wird man
zu herzen
ich glaube kaum dass ich dass ich beim
fall aus dem dritten stock sterben würde
na gut aus dem weg ich hab mir das ganz
oben jetzt hat eine ende folge jobcenter
perlen brauche ich und zwar eine wenn
mir irgendwo meine hin die kürzlich zum
camping feier von dem ich glaube
gesprochen dafür ändert ja erst eins von
den campers beendet werden gebt einfach
mal bei der suche alter nein diese
steuerung dann brauchen wir das rote
davon
sehr schön sind jetzt schon ganz oben
wer sich ganz nach oben gehen damit ja
das war cool also ich bin total also
ganz oben ja genau
jetzt soll ich dir einfach wie bei einem
em bei dem ende portal anordnen
das heißt eine basis aus zwei ländern ja
also eine basis aus 2 und 1 3 hoch an
den seiten also 244 breit fünf hoch er
ist ein reporter vier bright eyes 2 in
der mitte frei bleiben müssen
und ja ja ja genau zeigen also
eigentlich zwei breit
ja gut findest du sagst und drei hoch
okay ich hab voll voll die aussetzung so
heißt es 363 hoch heisst je zwei wochen
die drei hoch muss es doch eigentlich
doch so sitzen leute was macht das für
eine partei ich hoffe das reicht in die
als dimension
ja das recht das heißt nicht genau ob
das reicht was für ein portal was jetzt
genau so ganz mitbekommen in die eis
dimension ich weiß auch nicht genau
gelesen also ich hab ich lese mir so ein
bisschen was an um da die ganze sache
ein bisschen spannender zu machen so ich
habe ich sieben schnell sagt 'weißt du
was es so in der city und so tolles gibt
oder ja da gibt zum beispiel traders die
einem für waffen viel stärke waffen
geben und so habe ich eine sache
brauchen ärzte und zwar ist ziemlich
ressourcenintensiv 60 minuten das machen
doch wir haben doch wir brauchen noch
eine twilight club ok und die muss man
aus neuen uhren machen
gold intensiv ja also viel gold und 1
redstone das über 630 gold aber ich
mache ja klar
das heißt wir einfach die vorteile der
anderen regionen die haben mich noch
kein portal und weist wenn wir zuerst
dimension sind können wir nicht
theoretisch an zuerst den boss auch
klatschen und soweit click game folgen
auch keine ahnung wie sie die bosseborn
ich weiß wie man boss band also ich weiß
über den ersten boss der mann tötete und
die angel entity ist dass die die im
trailer ist ich weiß gar nicht dass die
außen sieht aus wie eine riesige
heuschrecke dies baut mit sonderurlaub
aber wie wollen wir den kannst du
einfach ich sag's nicht der hauptname
dass die andere stadt
ich schreibe dir daher mir dass es ist
einfach es ist einfach wenn man sich
dumm aber ab aber die wirft die wirklich
irgendwie 30 blöcke hoch oder so wenn du
dich dumm anstellen was dieser tolle
sachen sagt auch nicht walter alter york
ok gold und redstone alles klar
nur einstecken ich hoffe schon dass
ackermann gesagt kann man jetzt machen
dass ihr achtung sagt sie
zack zack zack zack zack zack twilight
klopp ja ok neuen redstone und ja es war
schon war halt viel gold eine sechste
gold aber dafür ist er ist ein krasser
strategischer vorteil
ich hoffe nur dass die andere region
main gebiet ist nicht schaut wenn
irgendeiner feuchtes sieht vor allem wer
i um diese visa veri um der immer meine
videos guckt schreibt einfach mal die
kommentare ob das sie gesehen hast
wirklich interessieren würde ich sagen
will ich im ultra gerne weil du ja so
ahnung hast mit dem wir eigentlich
machen wir machen
nun müsste jetzt eigentlich in die
universität müssen wir schauen wie wir
sie als ich hab jetzt schon die
grundform für mainball chor so und dann
gehts dann der nächsten folge weiter
aber alle als allererstes das highlight
der heutigen folge ganz nach oben hier
um zu kapieren dass man die löcher im
boden
ok jetzt hoffentlich klappt's ja
hoffentlich klappt okay noch 321 nichts
passiert das musst du dir doch es klappt
halt ein bisschen gedauert
wir haben
die wir einfach schon also bei mir sind
achten folge direkt schon zum portal
haben ist meine sechste folge
ich würde sagen ich würde auf jeden fall
seinen bissen probieren jetzt auch bei
20 minuten da würde ich wirklich sagen
ich probiere jetzt noch schnell ein
dieses fall holder und maus macht
vielleicht ein bisschen breiter und dann
sehen wir uns irgendwann in der nächsten
folge hier auf meinem journal oder auf
dem von marios so kommt man hier
ich mache jetzt noch schnell dieses fall
noch dass er echt geil
ich glaub ich mach's 4 x 4 das besser
also etwas habe ich viermal 4244 blöcke
wir können uns eigentlich auch mal
aufzubauen weiß wie beim autokauf zug
aus raps anbaut
wir können es einfach einen auszug aus
weingarten muss einfacher weiß wie man
das macht ja bei myspace erhält einfach
rechts x-men destiny alte alter was aber
auch zu geht halt nur hoch ja ich hab
ich dann gedacht aufzug austricksen kann
ich aufbauen aber der unendlich viel
platz weg
unendlich viel platz haben wir nicht ja
auf jeden fall endlich platzt aber so
okay mein haus mein kann ich bauen so
als mache das hier mal sagt wir machen
machte stellt dieses fall auch hier
fertig werdet schon leicht über 20
minuten aber du fehlst jede folge ja ich
weiß wie kathleen hero hat habe ich
brauche schon noch schnell ganz hoch und
probier es einmal aus okay danke ja
walter ich würde sagen wir trauen uns
erstmal nicht so und ich so kraft hätten
hiess sich das dann hier auch einmal die
das wasser dann verschwindet dann steht
eigentlich in fast jeder will man sagen
oh gott
gerade das ist echt tief ich habe
sowieso voll höhenangst das ist hält
sich auch im angriff nicht so wirklich
in grenzen
nein alter das ist übel hochmoor hier
halt jetzt noch ganz oben
ok so komme ich her und machen uns
irgendwie noch ein flottes aufzug hin
jetzt will ich mal sagen leute probiere
das war auch okay
321 alter ok alles klar das funktioniert
es ist also noch überlegen über das
hochkommen aber das werden wir in der
nächsten folge machten
heute würde ich sagen was ich gefallen
hat last einen daumen nach oben da
schreibt in die kommentare was ihr euch
von mir wünsche dass in dem projekt
mache hat der sagen ein
mitbestimmungsrecht will ich sagen
haut rein macht's gut und